good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday I was
confizzled Miss Frizzle was frazzled
because it's Tuesday it's my first day
back in studio we did an episode
yesterday we recorded it on Sunday but
it is in case you were frizzled like me
it is Tuesday
which is exciting for us because it's
inadvertently the week is off kilter
giving The Vibes of a short week though
it is not it's actually very much like a
a week you know it's it's giving week
it's giving weak like there's so much
going on in the world I think it's you
don't even know I don't want to trigger
you it is you and week the streets are
barricaded if you live anywhere near the
U.N wishing you well best of luck God
speed to you and your family the
president is in town it's not normal
like the way I always feel this way like
if I was the president which oh my God
how lucky would you all be
um I would never leave the house like I
know like as a president like you have
to do stuff like outside of your house
but the way it inconveniences my
subjects I would be acutely aware too
um and I would like the way the whole
city has to shut down for one
[ __ ] person like it's giving
unnecessary
I agree and you know who was all about
that life who the queen yeah never
brought everyone to her like made sure
her homes for centuries Pat who have
been palaces so true she would want to
spend all of her time in and and the
people came to her so true but now it's
like all of that energy is
inverted because I don't know if you
watched the funeral yesterday but the
whole city is I'm sorry for this woman
which is so it was so gorgeous we'll
talk about it but that's once every
every 75 years right right because she's
just like a selfless Queen and we'd like
that for her it's crazy how I still have
so much mid-september trauma like I'm
still thinking like is it you end league
right no that's the way your brain is
wired and we're miles miles and miles
apart
by the way that was great second of all
now that you just got me thinking like
when you compare Buckingham Palace to
the White House like the White House is
like tacky as [ __ ] like it's giving like
gross because every four years there's
like a new person they redecorate like
the queen is like so old school like
it's only her family who's lived there
for years and years
um but when I like think of the White
House comparing it to Buckingham Palace
I'm like oh
yeah I think there's pros and cons to
both from what I understand like these
palaces are old and they require so much
upkeep and it's like impossible there's
you know wallpaper crumbling I think
they they have like rats and stuff all
the time uh it's really hard to keep
them up I do think the White House it's
more modern because it's only true
centuries old compared to like and they
redecorate every couple of years right
so you know kum's a fresh I actually
think it's tabula rasa
tabula rasa that's the thing it always
comes back to tabula rasa yeah like if I
were in the White House you know every
room would be
um
if I was in the White House the whole
thing dead ass would be for my fair
oh for sure because I have unlimited
like expenses I've like I could do
whatever I want like I want Wayfair
yeah and a Sprinkle of Jonathan Adler
which they do sell on Wayfair
Wayfair is is really great sometimes
right not when they're trafficking
children right oh my God I like can't
ever forget about that unfortunately you
could no everyone forgot no they haven't
I actually had a really pleasant
experience with Wayfair a few weeks ago
like oh yes tell everyone that was the
craziest thing everyone uh so I ordered
some outdoor furniture from Wayfair
because Furniture is just so expensive
and so I was like I'm gonna try Wayfair
I got one set of things that was like
pretty meh and like what you expect from
Wayfair like definitely should have
checked the weight limit but then I
ordered something else and something got
delivered
and it wasn't what I ordered I ordered a
couch and instead I got two big chairs
but they were like the same brand the
same coloring they clearly just like
picked picked the wrong item on the
Shelf but they did they were nice
looking and they matched what I was
waiting to get so I called Wayfair I
told them they sent the wrong thing they
made me send pictures blah blah blah and
at the end they were like and you can
just keep that or donate it whatever you
see fit it's not worth the cost to us to
like bring it back to the warehouse and
it matches the thing that I'm having
coming I have this gorgeous outdoor set
no um I've sat in it it's literally
stunning it's so premium only had to pay
for half of it and they were so kind and
they were so they were like the customer
experience was so pleasant they were so
pleasant on the phone I was also
pleasant too so I think like you get out
what you put in so Josh and Ben I
couldn't be bothered because I was like
this is your guys's problem yeah like
you'll come pick it up I'm not dealing
with it Josh and Ben I'm not gonna
stress out about it on good guys they
were talking about this like customer
service you know behavior and it was
such a funny conversation because Josh
was telling me like the audience what he
does and it's exactly what I do doing
he's 100 right that you will get so far
with just this one tactic I've been
doing it for years let's cosplay okay so
you're gonna be Susan from Delta or
whatever okay oh but I'm Delta okay
whatever like you're Susan from Amazon
well it's okay it just depends on like
what the place is because I'm when
you're on the phone with an airline it's
impossible to be nice because you've
just had the worst actually
um uh like I've used this tactic
exclusively with Delta because that's
really the customer service that I call
the most okay I'll be Susan from Delta
okay
ring ring
hello Susan from Delta who am I speaking
with hi this is Claudia Susan how are
you thank you so much for picking up
me nobody ever asked about right right
you repeat back the name and you ask how
the person is there is so much like and
Josh is disarming yes Josh was saying
that he does that I'm like oh my God I
do that too like saying someone's name
especially someone who works in customer
service and who's used to being
railroaded just like that tiny bit of
like Personal Touch I think goes such a
long way and I like pretty I have pretty
good customer service experience with a
lot of companies because I'm always
don't get me wrong I've had those
moments but I'm like hi yeah I'm here my
thing is not here like I've had those
moments but always try and say the
person's name and just ask them how they
are at the beginning it is seriously it
goes such a long way
okay thank you for that tip of the day
you catch more flies with honey than you
do with vinegar yeah from Claudia and
there's just something really personal
about saying someone's name especially
when you're in a job where I feel like
most of the people you interact with
couldn't give less of a [ __ ] what your
name is
yeah
so what you're saying is call me by your
name
um
fun fact about me never seen that movie
oh me neither added to the list of like
big movies that everyone no I don't
think that no that movie has so much
adoration from like a niche audience
it's not I don't think it's like a mega
I've never seen it either and people
like don't care
they don't they don't come for you no
and I feel like I know a lot of people
actually who haven't seen that movie oh
look at you well maybe for me it's just
because Rebecca and Dana like it's their
favorite movie they both had read the
book it's like their thing it's just
like it was a book first and maybe it's
like me feeling left out maybe this is
like some sort of internal like you're
you're this is like therapy
maybe no a movie I've never seen like in
full
um is Wedding Crashers and like that's a
big deal that is a big deal because it's
amazing no I know and like it's always
on cable so like I'll watch it I I
always found myself watching it when I'm
getting ready for a show because like
I'm in a hotel that just has cable and
it's like movies we love on E it's
always on so I'm like watching a cup
I'll watch an hour and I'll see 25
minutes of the movie because of the
commercials you should sit down with it
honestly it's really that good no I know
but like I've made it this far now it's
just an interesting fact about me you
know
oh she's so interesting an interesting
fact about a movie that I ruined for
myself because I didn't sit down with it
and I just turned it on is Gone Girl I
can't I never read the book I turned the
movie on in the middle remind me what
movie this is Ben Affleck Rosamund Pike
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] I get that movie
confused with girl on a train yeah yeah
that makes sense but I think I've seen
Gone Girl you have she goes missing she
goes missing and for the first half it's
like spoiler alert if you've never seen
it just she goes missing first half is
she alive is she dead like did Ben
Affleck do it it turns out she
orchestrated the whole thing right to
make her husband look guilty but I
turned it on in the middle so I never
had the question of I always knew she
was alive
yeah you know I mean that's kind of a
crazy thing to do to like turn on a
movie you've never seen and watch it
from The Middle
I I had no idea so I played myself on
that congratulations experience I didn't
get to experience it congratulations you
played yourself yeah
yeah
um so it's
a dragon recap but we were delayed
because I was traveling this weekend I
watched it on the plane last night when
I tell you I actually rewound and watch
the wedding scene again because I was
like quaking were you wouldn't it
spoiler alert when Damon like put his
hand around her neck I swear to God I
paused
oh I I watched it last night too I the
episode that didn't do that much for me
okay we'll talk about it in the official
TV recap I in fact I even watched the
explainer at the end just to make sure I
saw whatever
uh it was interesting but I'm I have
questions for you because I downloaded
it offline on HBO Max on the HBO Max app
on my computer which is riddled with
issues like can somebody get with the
program and I guess the director's
explanation doesn't make it in that
version because I was ready I was like
great I have six hour flight let me
watch this 20 minutes where the director
explains because I was a little confused
about what happened at the end of the
episode and it wasn't even listening
tsunami listening to the podcast by the
way I'm down
yeah they should only if they have Matt
Smith on he should host it and I believe
they joined TNN
not to make everything about us but
somehow it always finds its way back
right and to make it about me I just
wanted to say I got home late last night
seven hour delay oh my God like kill me
um from the pnw Pacific Northwest and I
have to say Seattle is literally
stunning like the weather is I mean I'm
sure like during the winter it sucks but
like while it's still 85 degrees here
they're like falling into fall over
there and it's a city by the water and
it was so crisp like really the most
stunning weather I was obsessed okay
there was a like a small chill in the
air but it was still summer you know
that's so nice it was really nice and
the toast is like so like popular in
Seattle it's like so Random to me and
like whenever we're like going through
demographics for tour or anything I'm
always like oh yeah Seattle like we're
weirdly like big there I feel that
because I feel like if you like Seattle
weather yeah you like our personality
it's the chili girls there's something
very correlative between between like
people and weather and we are cold
weather people it's totally correlative
you know like are we big in Arizona I
wouldn't be surprised if we're not uh we
actually are
I'd love that for us well because they
like to party that's the thing um we're
just like big everywhere because this is
the number one show on the planet and
we're big girls so that kind of makes
sense you know I wonder what state we're
the least popular in
you would know
well no it's States I've never been to
right like I really want to do a show in
Iowa like it's my dream I would make you
come and we would literally Farm Shop
Farm shop but I think it's too small of
an audience to even go you know you'll
never know if you don't try Claude and
maybe that's how you become big in Iowa
like they see you on the Marquee they're
like okay it's Saturday night who what
who's playing the theater oh my God I
sneezed on it it's true
I'll go with you if you if you book a
show I will I really want to
okay goals you have to always have goals
it was such a great weekend though you
know I've been like every time I take
like a quick not even a quick like I
haven't been on stage since
Red Bank which was end of August so like
about a month
I always am like I'm a fraud no one's
coming I'm not funny like I have a total
reset it's like the first time I'm ever
doing stand up and I have terrible
anxiety and I can't sleep
um so just to like be reaffirmed that
like it's I'm still great this is
literally what I was born to do it was
so fun and it was such it was kind of
crazy like I know it's still America but
there's something about the Pacific
Northwest from New York that feels so
far it feels like a different country I
mean it's a six hour flight which is
just insane I just feel like it really
shouldn't have to take that long
um and it's a totally different culture
and I actually felt like I was playing a
show in another country and it was like
wow I'm so big in this country
that's nice do you know what I'm saying
for you I do know what you're saying it
did feel like you were really far yeah
and people like were messaging me like
what do you think about pnw nobody ever
says that about Cleveland they're like
it's just it's like a city you know but
they were like I'm so curious to hear
your thoughts on the pnw because it is
like this totally weird different not in
a bad or a bad way like it's just this
kind of remote part of the country that
I feel like exists within itself I hope
I'm not offending anyone I'm not meaning
I'm saying in a positive way no yeah and
you said that you love Seattle I loved
Seattle Portland was cute too but I
didn't spend as much time in Portland I
was there literally for three hours and
I was on Robitussin so I was asleep the
whole time yeah oh yeah speaking of the
sick girls we're feeling better yeah
um I I sounded so sick on yesterday's
episode you did I like finished my
illness and then I also caught a cold so
it was like a twofer and then for the
last since Saturday night I like tweaked
my neck oh my God I'm I was not okay I
don't know if it's got if it's healed
yet it's been like slowly creeping up
throughout the day and by the end of the
day like I actually can't move
um right now I'm okay but that was just
that was undeserved that was not fair
I'm super happy you're okay but more
importantly how's roldini's neck
his neck is good it's good yeah his neck
is getting stronger than ever you're
taking care of the neck yeah his neck
it's come really a long way in the last
few months because you know babies are
born babies don't have Max yeah he went
from being no neck too man with a neck
big strong neck big strong neck so his
neck is doing well and that's actually
more important I would take several
bullets for that neck it's so warm and
soft and I swear to God like I could
sleep there
also speaking of you taking bullets
something that's been cracking me up is
like behind you in the studio yes yes
there is a little hole from where the
neon sign used to hang and someone said
like it looks like a bullet hole yes and
to me it's representative of all of the
um metaphorical bullets that you take
for everyone on The Daily yeah no I I
could spackle it but it's a metaphor and
symbolism metaphor symbolism is a
Cornerstone principle of the morning
toast and what you see above my head if
you're watching on YouTube is a physical
manifestation of all the bullets I would
take for each and every one of you
because Band-Aids don't fix bullied
holes
you say sorry just for show if you live
like that you live with gold
we're like Loki really creeping up on
the release of Midnight's Taylor's new
album
um
and it's just it's so nice to have a
life you know I feel like for the last
couple of years like I really haven't
had a life so I basically just sit
around waiting for things to happen but
I'm so booked and busy that like things
are just happening yeah in the words of
Sheena Marie Shea
it's all happening speaking of Taylor I
watched the summer I turn pretty oh yeah
your commentary was cracking me up
honestly I forget who was I on the phone
with I think I was on FaceTime with my
friend Abe
when you had texted me about the Summer
I Turned Pretty and I was literally
cackling I was like Jackie's so [ __ ]
funny like I I feel this way like I I
obviously suck the air out of every room
like I stuck the air out of the podcast
like if I wasn't around everyone would
be like oh my God Jackie is funnier than
Claudia like you are so [ __ ] funny
Jackie was sending me text messages if
you watched the summer I turn pretty of
the scene where belly gets drunk off
those like cranberry margaritas and ends
up pushing the woman with cancer down
the stairs
um and her commentary was so [ __ ]
funny but tell me what you thought okay
I I'm really happy for the campers that
they have like content like this I
personally I'm double belly's age so I
was feeling like just a little too old
to be watching it but
it was really she's really a sweetheart
but like I just can't relate to her and
like I please explain to me why they
call her belly like if I was 15 years
old and everyone was calling me belly
like I would be like triggered well if
you I mean I don't know what most normal
16 year olds have in terms of like
self-esteem or like body image awareness
I guess like okay if anybody called me
belly right now like literally you're
taking it yeah
jail
um but I think like 16 you're like young
enough to still be like Carefree about
your body oh what a time to be young
yeah so but her name is Isabel right so
it's a belly yeah Isabella it was
interesting just to watch it from the
perch of like an older person it's like
okay this is what the kids are up to
this is really like wholesome content
for kids to be watching like I'm here
for that but
um I find myself like watching it more
from like the parent perspective which
is so crazy and I'm like
these kids some of the some of them like
belly is such a good kid and like you
can only hope that you know she stays
the track yeah she's like that she is
just you know the model child but like
the boys were being like so moody and
mean and I was like Ugh is that what I
have to look forward to but you know
what that was like a I mean I thought
they did a good job that was like such a
palpable thing in the book it's like her
family like they're so [ __ ] mean to
her like her brother I wanted to kill
like he was so mean to her in the book
and like you end up feeling so bad for
her but that's really what it's like to
be a teenage girl who's like surrounded
by like cousins and brothers like they
leave you out and they're mean to you
and they throw you in the pool and it
was like you feel so sorry for belly and
that really did translate very well to
the show it did but then it's also like
she gets to go to The Debs with all the
girls who are obsessed with her brother
and her cousins yeah she's the cool
she's that bad really cool she's that
[ __ ] so like I didn't feel that bad for
her for that long I also found myself
like I'm more interested in the Love
Story between Stephen and uh what with
Shayla I don't know I watch a show like
six months ago the brother and his
girlfriend by the end like they're fully
in love like they're actually going
through stuff throughout the show and
I'm like I want their book yeah well I
don't did you didn't read the book did
you no no and I'm glad I didn't yes so
the it's really kind of
um
really similar the only few things they
changed were Jeremiah is not bisexual in
the book
um and there is no debutante ball and
even though it was like this big thing
in the show it's not it did it's like
not that big of a deal I don't really
feel like it changed that much for me
because it was like the show needed like
benchmarks throughout the season you
know like end of summer what are we yes
I agree I'm that's shocking that
debutant wasn't in the book I know but
like it didn't bother me and okay so
like yes you thought it was like
childish and a little immature but like
when he gets up to dance with her at the
dead ball and they play that Taylor
Swift song like you died right I I
actually did die okay and I I'm very
team Conrad duh and I I like him as a
person
um I like him for belly and I just like
I he's very handsome and you don't know
what happens right
no I just watched the first season so
this is the first season is the first
book okay and they end on the beach and
spoiler alert Conrad and belly kiss yeah
yeah
um like the way
it's not like a traditional like happily
ever happened like what happens is
[ __ ] crazy
oh I can't wait to hear but I don't
think that it's gonna be like they
honestly shouldn't have kissed because
he's about to go to college and like
meet real women and it's gonna make
belly look even younger like if they're
ever gonna have a chance of being
together forever like she needs to get a
little bit older because he's on the
precipice of adulthood and she's a
sophomore you just have to wait like
you'll say the the show covers a span of
I think like 10 years
wow yes so they grow up that's like tell
me lies on Hulu which you really I know
I need to read the book well no wait I
heard that the show is so different from
the book oh but the show is amazing and
I feel like if I read the book and then
the show was different it would be like
comparing just watch the show okay okay
I will then
and did you start a new book on the
plane I did so I finished the series
um by Abby Jimenez which is so [ __ ]
good like
I want to recommend this book like first
of all there's a major trigger warning
it's like really covers a lot of
infertility and it was so [ __ ] sad
um but like the name of the book is
called the friend zone and on the cover
it's like two cartoons and so I thought
I was getting ready for like some porn
you know
um Not only was there like no porn which
I didn't mind it was like the most sad
serious book I cried two times why the
[ __ ] is it called the friend zone like
at no point are they even friends like
it's
it was like really misleading and I feel
like if people knew what it was about
they would want to read it more and then
there's a sequel which was like silly
and cute and fun whatever
um but the first part it's called the
friend zone and then the second one is
the Happy Ever After playlist and then
there's like a playlist that goes along
with it which is really cute
um the friend zone by Abby Jimenez is
incredible like it was so good I think I
finished it and I swear to God 30
minutes I was obsessed
um then on the plane I started city of
likes by Jenny Mullen that you told me
to read and it's super good except like
uh the protagonist makes me want to kill
like myself like she's so [ __ ]
depressing
um she literally makes me never want to
become a mom the way she like talks
about motherhood I'm like this is what
it is like yeah she's like stressed to
the nine she's so [ __ ] stressed and
she's like not helping her case and
honestly her husband [ __ ] sucks yeah
um but I see the makings of a good book
like you're totally right it's someone I
like I hate when people write about like
social media or just like a certain
thing
which is totally you could tell is from
an outsider's perspective yes she writes
it's about influencers and social media
and like she really Nails it and she
nails like that like Chelsea house is
obviously so has I'm a member of Soho's
like she Nails everything about like
these membership clubs like she's
totally right
yeah so that's why it's really good I
Dana recommended it to me I would
recommend it to anyone city of likes and
I read it so quickly like it was really
just an enjoyable read so maybe I will
just watch tell me lies on Hulu before I
um
read the book yeah it reminds me of sex
lives of college girls I don't know if I
told you that you did so I love sex
lives of college girls I know it was
good to be back there okay good so
contemplates are fall I still haven't
watched Manti Te'o but it's totally on
my list of things to do
um I'm just like so busy like I said
booked busy
um I have another show this weekend in
Long Island it's my last show in New
York and I think everyone should come
tickets available at girls no job.com
tour I love performing in Long Island
like on Long Island sorry
um there's really nothing like it
I'm excited for everyone thank you and
for you thank you and it's Rosh Hashanah
next week which means we're encroaching
upon Yom Kippur season so everyone just
keep that in mind but first up we have
our shashana which is a nice holiday
it's the Jewish New Year we're going to
reset renew and it's gonna be nice
it is gonna be nice so I think without
further ado
we could get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
today's episode is brought to you by
Spritz Society So based on the idea that
taste matters Jackie Ben and I created
Spritz Society after seeing a market
need for a canned cocktail that actually
tastes good so you guys know Spirit
Society is our brand it is canned
cocktails we come in five different
flavors we are delicious we're
carbonated we're all natural we've got
blood orange pineapple lemon grapefruit
and most recently Peach which is really
climbing the ranks to be everyone's
favorite flavor
um and now we have the founder favorite
bundles so if you don't know what to try
first then you can trust us Ben Jackie
and I each created bundles of our
favorite flavors that you can buy at
spritzociety.com each bundle comes with
six four packs of our absolute favorite
flavors so Jackie's comes with three
Peach and three pineapple mine come with
three grapefruit and three lemon I love
mixing grapefruit with tequila it's also
good on its own and lemon is like it's
giving Poland Spring energy it's
refreshing it's delightful and sometimes
I forget that there's wine in it so you
get an 18 savings when you buy the
bundle
um it's too good of a deal to pass up
since you're ordering so many packs
we're getting you 18 off and the founder
favorite bundles are now available on
spritzociety.com and you can shop today
thank you mclartium you're welcome okay
our first story The Queen has been laid
to rest Monday morning was her funeral
procession in the UK and some celebs
turned out making this a toasty story
totally
Bear Grylls and Sandra Oh and more
celebs attend Queen Elizabeth II's
funeral it was Bear Grylls like that
sounds familiar Man vs Wild
is it bear gryllis
it's spelled with a Y so got it okay but
you know man versus wild and like then
Zac Efron's always trying to like be him
yeah yeah
um but he Sandra Oh and Sophie
winkelmann were among the celebrities
who attended Queen Elizabeth II's
funeral at Westminster Abbey on Monday a
lot of people were very confused as to
why Sandra Oh was in attendance but she
um has won a medal for in as a
member of the Order of Canada and she
went as a representative which was
exciting and Bear Grylls represented the
scouts at the state funeral because he
is Chief Scout of course he is of course
I mean if he's not Chief Scout there's
nefariousness okay I mean the fact that
Sandra Oh got to go and Sandra Oh also
happens to be the actress who said
The Queen Is Coming is really art
imitating life yeah no that's how you
know like there's a God and he's making
things make sense or that's how you know
that we're living in a simulation
because like that simulation Tings
yeah it is someone's [ __ ] with us
yeah it's like a little too on the nose
it is but it was wonderful to see her
there the funeral's actually not that
star-studded considering what we've seen
like from wedding weddings and such but
it was very very serious very focused on
her majesty and I know it's like not
about this particular thing but like the
Royal women looked like it was for the
history books like there's a picture of
Kate going viral where she's just like
wearing her hat in her veil and she's
looking forward and her Glam is like
sickening the palace down and that photo
like remember how when Harry and Megan
like had their last Royal event and that
she wore that blue dress and it was
raining and there were all the lights
and they took those like movie star
textbook pictures this picture of Kate
is in the textbook too like it's so
stunning yeah she's also wearing the
Queen's pearls and earrings and I think
a brooch as well
speaking of photos the one of Princess
Charlotte crying after the funeral like
no kids are so real like they're gonna
keep it real you know yeah it was really
a beautiful 10-day procession the
funeral itself and all the uh Fanfare
Fanfare it was it was very moving it was
a funeral fit for a queen
it was it was moving and you know I feel
like there hasn't been a lot of like
there's tablets stuff because people
pick apart everything but as it pertains
to like Harry and Megan like with the
family I feel like there's really
nothing happening which is good like no
news is good news there's nothing real
happening but like every single headline
is about so-and-so was sitting here they
were in this right right like Harry
doesn't salute because like well I
actually thought that was interesting
like when they all all the family in
their uniforms like walk by and they
salute because Harry is not a working
Royal he doesn't salute and he's not in
his uniform so he doesn't salute right
but he wasn't his uniform for some of it
for one thing yeah he looked really hot
like I I was feeling it uniform maketh
man no and now I know what they say like
why they say there's something about a
man in uniform like there is
no there is and it's working for all of
them every single one especially because
you know the Hat covers William's head
so he was like mature balding and you
know Harry's also premature it's
obviously a genetic thing and if I
thought that James Hewitt was his father
I now
um don't because I've really noticed
through all these pictures that he's
balding could be coming from Diana's
side because Charles has a nice head of
hair
that's so true
yeah it's happening to Harry too how
much younger is Harry than William
uh that's a great question let's get
some answers he's 38. who
Harry sorry that wasn't clear helpful
and William is
40.
oh so they're like super close in age
yeah William looks much older
yeah I don't know not with that uniform
on no he should walk around in that all
day long and I think now he has to oh
also everyone in the family is moving on
up like Charles inherited queenie's
estate William and Howard Charles a
billion dollar estate wow they're all
getting houses jewelry
um so it's really genuinely quite
literally the end of an era
yeah and I saw I think that now that the
public morning period is over like the
family will now mourn in private I think
King Charles is going to Balmoral so
hopefully they get some time off to
actually you know deal with the loss in
their life and uh things might be quiet
yeah I'm sure Harry and Megan are
running back to California I don't think
I think of anything like this whole Saga
reinforced for them but like probably
specifically Megan how like happy they
are to not be working Royals
yeah well I think maybe in this one
moment they maybe wish that they were to
be a working role yeah because they
would have been in the front room
without wearing the uniform and not
everything would have felt like they
were second in line yeah they would have
been more a part of it that's true too
but I think like
it's probably like traumatizing like
when you're back in it it's like
reminding of all the reasons why you
left like the town and I'm sure it's
worse than ever now because then ever
it's happened yeah yeah so um I will
miss seeing you know the gang back
together but it's time for everyone to
go back to their separate sides of the
the Earth planet the pond Pond thank you
um yeah no I'll miss
I'll miss it all I'll miss her yeah
the new era begins King Charles Cavalier
Spaniel Bryce is the king of the UK
I would I knew and he has risen to the
challenge I'm actually Theo's older so
he would probably be the king
yeah that's true oh my every time I look
at Bryce and I'm just like King Charles
I'm just like bowing my head curtsying I
wonder what kind of dogs King Charles
has and why they aren't King Charles's
we don't know if they are they aren't
yet we wouldn't but the thing is we
would know if they are like everyone
would be sending it to us
so they're not so they're not
missed opportunity another excellent X
in the Charles column
he's making it hard so hard oh my God
these temper tantrums he's throwing girl
no it's it's low-key embarrassing girl
the queen would never it's giving
toddler energy
73 year old toddler 73 year old toddler
are you ready for our next story which
is really the big celeb news of the day
yes model Summoner stroke claimed she
had an affair with Adam Levine an
Instagram model is going viral on Tick
Tock Monday for accusing Adam Levine of
having an affair with her the women's
Summoner Strow did not identify the
cheating party at first only calling him
a man who is married to a Victoria's
Secret model and then showing
screenshots of DMS with his whole last
name the Maroon 5 front man has been
married to former Victoria's Secret
Angel Behati Prince loose in 2014. she
said Sumner quote at the time I was
young I was naive and quite frankly I
felt exploited I wasn't in the scene
like I am now so I was definitely very
easily manipulated however uh yeah but
sorry at the time it was 2022 so just
keep it was it 2022 like a lot of her
screenshots were from this year oh okay
so yeah at the time so I guess she
became in the scene like unless last
week yes yeah
um she said that the affair took place
last year when she graduated college in
2021 and she posted in the video you
know that they had an affair it was
whatever she wasn't going to say
anything but that Adam Levine then DM
her saying okay serious question I'm
having another baby and if it's a boy I
really want to name it Sumner you okay
with that dead serious
there's so much to unpack here let's
let's unpack the part that like Adam
Levine cheats on his wife if with women
he meets on Instagram I'm sure there's
more women because you don't just like
do it once you know it's like obviously
no and you don't act like this casual
about it right right it's a one to big
deal and of course that makes me hate
Adam Levine I never particularly like
was obsessed with him but like I was
into him you know Maroon 5 is a good
band
um I have literally no respect for him I
think it's disgusting his wife is
pregnant and he's still dm'ing this girl
um this is like musician Tings this is
not surprising this is what people in
Hollywood do
et cetera Etc
what I found to be so interesting was
this video and this video came up for me
naturally on my for you page and then I
like watched it digested it and then my
for you page became inundated with
commentary on this situation because the
girl's energy in the video is so bizarre
in Cavalier for someone who's admitting
to having an affair with a married man
who has a baby on the way you know
um and a third baby a third I hate to be
like this girl
and it goes without saying like Adam
Levine is literally deplorable like this
is disgusting unethical Behavior or some
like I literally have no reason I have
just as much respect for this person as
I have for the [ __ ] on my shoe okay yeah
yeah
um but like low-key like you are part of
it too like you everyone knows he's
married he literally tells you as a baby
on the way like
like you should not be like making
videos like this is embarrassing for you
too like ew and like she didn't seem
apologetic she wouldn't even like say
bahati prinsloo's name she was like this
model like very dismissive and it's like
it's a very bizarre video because you're
exposing yourself
um and Adam for sure
but you're exposing yourself to and like
nobody asked and then you came out here
and said you literally like home wrecked
it takes two I'm sorry it takes two
people to wreck a home right I feel like
she's trying to position herself as like
a victim sort of it was giving victim
mentality and like that's that's not
gonna work for me no again like you
engaged yeah in this and by the way
there is totally totally totally a power
imbalance with like a mega mega star and
a girl who's clearly trying to become
famous whether it's through Instagram
through modeling like there's a power
imbalance
but you had an affair with a married man
right and so and so that is what it is
like asking then sort of like for
sympathy right that's where it doesn't
and then like you know obviously now
people are inundating her socials she
updated the caption on her most recent
Instagram post
to be like you know you know where to
find me for more content or whatever
like very promoting so it's just I don't
know what to make of the situation I
just think like Adam Levine like my
respect for him is completely depleted I
think he's gross but I also thought it
was just like a weird [ __ ] Flex like
so you're out here making this video
like admitting you did this horrible
unethical thing with Adam Levine like
you're both we're not supposed to like
focus on that we're supposed to focus on
the fact that he wants to name his baby
Summoner what did you just say no and
like what did you say and maybe someone
could explain that to me like the
discourse is very much like not us
blaming the woman no I'm blaming both of
you equally actually maybe a little bit
more Adam Levine since you're the one
with the wife but like you're a woman
you're supposed to like support your
fellow woman not [ __ ] her husband
yes and so a lot of the discourses like
well why are we focusing like I saw
Sarah Foster posted a photo I posted a
tick tock and it was like men who cheat
are disgusting
so are the women who cheat with married
men and the comments are like blowing
her up I guess you're like not a woman
who supports other women if you don't at
least acknowledge the fact like if you
acknowledge the fact that like it takes
two people a man and a woman to break up
a marriage like
if you even say that like you're not a
woman who supports other women and this
is why I don't support the whole like
journey of women supporting other women
like I think a good way to support women
is holding them accountable for their
mistakes no and to like not sleep with
their husbands right and not just like
blindly like oh well she's a woman so
she's like I actually think that
mentality like makes women weaker like
well she's a woman who got caught up
what women aren't capable of making
their own decisions right
I don't know I'm not into this at all
and I feel like it's really highlighting
for me
um this like what's wrong with the
concept of women supporting other women
I also think like this
sort of harks back to like this attempt
to like go viral yes and it's like you
don't even realize you're exposing
yourself and how terrible at what cost
right so I just
I I don't know she did what she thought
she was doing it's giving ble from
everyone involved big
loser energy but he is like majorly
exposed and I do think that for a lot of
people Adam Levine and bahati prince who
were like couple goals in like in a real
way yeah everything that I've seen of
their relationship so far is like so
sweet and they're you know they're three
kids they're in Hollywood they're both
huge stars like they seem truly in love
like okay so that's not what it seems I
think a lot of people's bubbles has been
burst and a lot of people like love Adam
Levine I'm gonna have to talk to Dana
about this because she loves maroon 5.
and I need to know like obviously this
is going to change how she looks at him
yeah no for sure that's a really good
point um I think if you're someone who
like
consumes a lot of celebrity media
um it's obviously you know
it's not great news but it's not
surprising like he is like a rock star
I know but that's why when it does seem
like it's a real the real thing and like
that these it's a real marriage and
they're in love and they're committed to
each other that's why we ship so hard
for couples that I think I just are that
I I wouldn't put Adam and bahati for me
in that category I feel like I've heard
things about him before like oh I never
had the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
like being nefarious like I feel like
I've heard things
I never heard anything this is like if I
heard something about
I don't even know who seems so great
anymore
yeah no nobody like everyone's letting
us down
yeah
oh do we have it as a story that Kelly
Clarkson got her star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame no I meant to
um if you want to bump one that you
don't like we could talk about a story
that is just I picked it for the it's
losery energy and I was excited to share
it with you
which is so long overdue but the reason
why I wanted to talk about it and why I
was like deeply moved was because you
know when you get a star in the Walk of
Fame you invite like a couple select
celebrity friends that's what makes the
thing like a photo op and she had Simon
Randy and Paula the original OG judges
of American Idol standing behind her and
I swear to God I could cry like it was
so
it was so moving
so moving and we love that Kelly like
never forget she came from and even
though I do think a lot of the American
Idol post Fame and the work was like
kind of really toxic for her like the
record label that you and automatically
sign on to and everything that comes
they own all your crap yeah I think she
had a hard time transitioning uh but
still she and like so much of where she
got to so much of how she got to where
she was like yes American Idol was a
huge launching Pad but like she worked
so hard she went through high she went
through lows like there are people carry
Underwood of course they don't have a
Morning Show like she's really gotten to
where she is so much in due to the fact
because that's just like what she was
meant to do and she works hard and she
has Star Quality and American Idol was
helpful in discovering that so it's very
cool that she is paying homage to where
she came from it's why we love Kelly
she's a down-home girl she remembers her
roots and I thought it was beautiful
Kelly that's beautiful Kelly that's
beautiful
I'm ready for our next and last week I
misspoke I don't think the Kelly
Clarkson show is permanently moving to
New York I think they did like Premiere
week for her season like big promo in
New York oh okay sorry sad for New York
so I guess we can't get tickets
tickets
are you ready for our next story oh wait
no
no she's not is it the next story that's
brought to you by canva Pro
yes creating visual content is an
essential part of what we do if you
follow us on social media you know we're
always churning out sickening content
and you might be shocked to learn that
Jackie nor I our graphic designers yet
all of our content looks like it was
made by a team of graphic designers but
that's because it was made by canva for
teams ever since we found canva for
teams it has been so easy to collaborate
and design with Jackie which makes the
whole process so much more creative and
fun canva for teams is a design platform
that makes it easy to create stunning
content in any format from social media
posts to videos presentations websites
the endless templates and premium fonts
photos graphics and videos add
personality and Edge to our content with
featured designs for brand consistency
canva for teams makes it easy to
maintain your aesthetic add your logos
your fonts your colors to anything you
create it also streamlines how we do
social media too so we can plan create
and share social media content directly
to all of our channels from one place
and even schedule posts ahead of time
which is great for weekends for
vacations when I'm on tour we're
scheduling content so we don't have to
be on our phones all time and we can be
present girlies
if you want to collaborate for with
canva for teams right now you can get a
free 45-day extended trial when you go
to canva.me toast that's c-a-n-v-a dot m
e slash toast for a free 45-day extended
trial we enjoy using canva teams so much
Jackie can go into a template mess
around then I can go and see Jackie's
changes it's collaborative it's easy it
makes it look professional canva dot me
slash toast love it by the way Adam
Levine has denied the affair oh he just
spoke to TMZ he said quote I use poor
judgment in speaking with anyone other
than my wife in any kind of flirtatious
manner I did not have an affair
nevertheless I crossed the line during a
regrettable period of my life he said
his interactions in certain instances
became inappropriate quote I have
addressed that and taken proactive steps
to remedy this with my family he said my
wife and my family is all I care about
in this world to be this naive and
stupid enough to risk the only thing
that truly matters to me was the
greatest mistake I could ever make I
will never make it again I take full
responsibility we will get through it
and we will get through it other well I
guess that's interesting in the sense
that her video had you know rock solid
proof that they were communicating not
that they were having an affair
yeah
so then he's calling her a liar well
he's saying what you saw in the video is
true I did message inappropriately and
in a flirtatious manner but she didn't
have any proof that they were ever
physically together maybe that's her
next video like he says they never had
an affair and then she's like boom
picture of us in bed
yeah maybe so I mean right now like he
has the benefit of the doubt because
there's no
proof of the affair there's just proof
of you know flirtatious messages which
is not okay to do if you're a married
man with children and also like
it's not just for the teachers
it's not just flirtatious no of course
not of course not but he is you know
leaning into the fact that that's the
only rock solid proof that she had
yeah perhaps but we'll have to see how
she responds it doesn't really change
anything I just hope that
he changes you know but it's up to
bahati and him I know and it's like
pregnant women don't need this stress no
like as a husband you're supposed to be
doing everything in your power to make
your pregnant wife lives easier not more
difficult and adding stress and making
her blood pressure go up which is not
good for the baby
yeah dick totally dick
next up don't worry darling premiered in
New York last night Miss Flo and Chris
Pine were not there but Margot ashrae
was there to save the day so Florence
Pugh has skipped out on yet another
event promoting don't worry darling this
time in New York City her and her
co-star Chris Prine pre-taped a message
for fans saying they were unable to
attend Monday's screening because she is
busy filming Dune part 2 in Europe and
he is in production in La she said we
did not want to miss this opportunity to
thank you for coming to experience don't
worry darling in IMAX Chris Pine
concluded the video by telling audiences
they were in for a thrilling ride and
that he hoped they enjoyed the movie so
for me like the big news of this
Premiere in New York is not that flow
and Chris Pine aren't there like at this
point I don't expect her to show up
anywhere and like Chris Pine is a
working actor sometimes people have to
miss things it's called schedule and I
do think it looks better for everyone
that Chris is also not there two people
are missing so it's like everybody's
working as opposed to adjustments flow
for me the takeaway I had from the
photos that came out from this event is
like and Margo like put something in my
brain a few weeks ago and now like it's
all I can think about she's like you
know that scene in Elvis when like he's
literally worked so hard he's can't get
up and they shoot him with something and
make him go on stage like Harry Styles
is doing a residency in Madison Square
Garden he goes to Venice Film Festival
he's doing all this promo there's so
much stress like he looked so tired at
this event like he looked much thinner
like he's just been like running on
empty and now I'm like seeing it through
the POV where it's like literally he
needs to take a nap
yeah I feel that everything he does at
MSG is just like so physical I know he
also has another movie coming out I
think it's called the basement the
policeman he's been doing pressed for
that
no wonder he gives us quotes like the
movie yeah like a movie wait that was a
cry for help nothing left to give it was
a cry for help like seriously somebody
needs to like Harry's being overworked
like that's really how I feel those
shows are so much work it's hours of
like singing dancing but giving
everything that you have traveling
Venice press policemen premieres
screenings like it's too much
and it's like this residency at MSG
which I'm thrilled about and I hope to
be able to see a show
um it's hella unnecessary he just did
like an American tour he ended it and
then it was like surprise 10 more shows
in New York why the tour's over
money
someone needs it someone is behind the
scenes shoving injection injecting his
ass with steroids like let him go to
sleep
yeah that's a good point and him and
Olivia like the pictures and the footage
is like giving it's giving no chemistry
I'm so convinced that they're not
together
do you think that any of the recent
drama has changed things between them
yeah
I mean because I don't know if this is
how it works when you're in a
relationship like with a fellow public
figure
um but if there's like drama from the
public figure and it's like it's the
backlash is kind of splashing on you
don't you have to evaluate like is this
relationship worth it it reminds me of
Sabrina Carpenter and Joshua Bassett you
know
yeah I agree and I think for a lot of
fair weather celebrities it's like get
your stain away from me right I don't
think Harry Styles is like that you
think he's scribbled I think he's
scrupled and I think he's like if I love
you I believe you like we'll ride this
out together
but what if like he didn't know about I
mean he got shy as part what if all this
time Olivia was like it was you I had to
fire Shia oh my God and Shia totally
exposed Olivia to the public and to
Harry yeah so that's the only thing I
don't think he cares about bad PR like
he has enough good will yeah for the
rest of his life but there's also just
the notion and the possibility that
they're not being even remotely in love
as in public for the film
um because they're being professional
and this is Olivia's directing not her
debut but it's like a huge deal for her
as a female director and maybe they're
just sticking with that
but I don't know if you were truly in
love even if you were being professional
I would see a twinkle you know
an elbow a shoulder shove you know
something now we're gonna be
professional after like Miss Flo had to
direct the movie because you guys were
nowhere to be found
also I didn't realize until I watched
the trailer like last week how big of a
movie this is I thought it was gonna be
like one of those of like two people
just like fighting in bed for three
hours you know no and that's why it's
like Stepford Wives meets Mad Max right
like it's honestly it's one of those
films that's like a film yeah it's so
true and it's not like an indie like I
think the reason why there was so much
press around Olivia
um wild being a director is because it
had like a big Studio behind it like it
had a huge budget so it's like that
doesn't happen a lot for female
directors
um and that's why variety was sitting
down with her like it's a huge thing
it's kind of like
Wonder Woman what's her name Patty
yeah Patti LuPone what's her last name
uh I'll look it up
put Patty Stanger what is her name
oh my God my typing just wondering
Google Wonder Woman Patty I was trying
that's what I was trying to do
Patty Jenkins Jenkins Jenkins
so um that's why it's a big deal yeah
it's like a big ass film and by the way
it looks so good like I definitely will
see it it does look good it's not what I
thought it was going to be at all no me
neither I thought it was going to be
like a marriage Story the one with
scarjo and Adam Driver because all the
the pictures that were coming out were
just the two of them in bed looking at
each other so I'm like do they leave the
bedroom yeah yeah no it's like this
whole world yeah
um it does it's giving separate wives
yeah so um we'll have to ask snitch how
it was and if she picked up on anything
at the premiere we'll have the exclusive
for you or you could check it out on the
snatcher yeah totally
are you ready for our next story which
is giving such looser energy I just
couldn't oh I'm sorry I couldn't deny
you I couldn't do it to you I would
never love his blind Stars deep div
potty and Kyle Abrams are no longer
dating just days after they confirm
their relationship the hate I have in my
heart for everyone from the second
season of Love is Blind like it knows no
bounds it is a deep deep hatred
and Kyle are going their separate ways
she announced he announced on Instagram
Monday that he and his co-star are no
longer dating he said I understand many
of you are curious as to whether where
deep T and I stand today since after the
altar was filmed we decided to go our
separate ways in early summer I've since
embarked on a new relationship when
which I intend to keep private for a bit
so they were like
kind of teasing everyone about like are
they aren't they together they were
being [ __ ] annoying yeah during the
reunion there was like some Sparks
happening but they wouldn't really speak
on it so I guess then they did start
dating and now they're not dating and I
truly don't care I I hate all of these
people like when I see them doing
interviews on podcasts like I will make
a mental note to never listen to that
podcast again like I like Natalie I
Shane like I hate all these people
because there's and you know what
what was so beautiful about season one
of Love is Blind is the people who
participated really did not know it was
going to be Netflix they didn't know it
was going to be this big old thing and
then when it became literally Bigger
Than The Bachelor the biggest show of
the year you attract the wrong type of
people and that's exactly what we got
like Deep D and Kyle like after the
season like being so [ __ ] annoying on
social media it's one thing to keep your
relationship private it's another thing
to use it as click bait and drag it out
and like giving thirsty energy and
that's what they were doing and I I just
started to hate and you know who I
started to like the villains Shayna okay
because she wasn't being annoying and
thirsty Justice for Shayna Justice for
Shayna also this guy is just red flag
Central first of all the fact that he
proposed to Shayna a woman he had
nothing in common with who was like not
interested in Desperate however and even
once they got together he like wanted to
stay engaged her like just to be on the
show yeah so thirsty 100 I'm so glad
we're having this conversation like I
how and I feel like DT really came out
like the hero of the season and so one
like how does she not see that in him
being like you really tried to stay
engaged to a girl who like you have
nothing in common with just to stay it
was he mean to you like sad and two the
other thing about deep deep was like the
whole season you really thought she I
forgot the name of her uh shake shake
you really thought she was trying to
make it work with shake and like
obviously Shake was extremely
problematic even more so towards the end
but like deep deep felt it looked like
she was really trying to make it work
and that she really liked him and that
and at some point that they were like
getting along in simpatico and like are
they or aren't they gonna get married
and at the end like she denies him and
chooses herself so it's like so were you
acting the whole time like she acted
like this was a big surprise for us
which it was but it's like we're not
supposed to be surprised we watched your
love story right he was an ass right but
like you were committed to it and then
no psych yeah you're not an actress no
the second season like made me hate the
whole franchise and like after the altar
after the altar part two like we don't
care we don't care
we don't care and that's what you need
to know happy for them don't care
are you ready for our fifth and final I
could tell I got a big loser energy
are you ready for a little sports news
yeah
10 is great Roger Federer insists that
he is retiring he says quote I am
definitely done the 20-time Grand Slam
winner tells today's Savannah Guthrie
that he will walk away from competitive
tennis following this weekend's Laver
Cup in London Roger Federer is
definitely done playing tennis he said
in an exclusive interview that he is
firm on his decision to end his playing
Savannah said you know unretiring is a
thing now Tom Brady now Serena seems to
be wavering a little does she done I
guess um by the way I'm so here for
Serena to unretire like I I don't think
she has anything I think she has
something left especially because when
you go out losing it's not a way to go
out
yeah so this actually I'm very
interested in because I'm reading Carrie
Soto is back the new Taylor Jenkins read
book which is about a tennis player at
the top of her game she eventually
retires and comes out of retirement and
that's what the book is and now I have
like a whole I actually have like
thoughts on this as opposed to being
like why do people retire why do they
right
um I don't know why he retired hopefully
it takes a big person to come out of
retirement no it kind of takes like like
a loser like honestly like for Tom Brady
like I just hate people who are
wishy-washy like retire or don't like
stop playing with us
I know but it's like when your whole
life I know has been committed to one
thing like it's how do you no that's
fair
especially when you feel like you have
more to give like so say Carrie Soto
retired because she got injured but then
she got her ACL repaired and just a few
years later like why not play again see
the thing with tennis is like obviously
all sports are physical but like tennis
is so physical you're not on a team it's
just you you gotta run you gotta jump
You Gotta Serve You Gotta swing like
it's really so labor intensive there's
no hiding like an injury no and so with
and you can't rely I mean unless you
play doubles but like you can't rely on
a teammate so I feel like especially
with the men's I feel like all of the
greats are like getting up there in age
like Raphael Nadal Roger Federer um
those are the only ones I know uh a joke
he's old too like I feel like we're
ushering in like a new wave of like big
tennis players like I I didn't watch US
Open but everyone was obsessed with this
guy and I'm so sorry because I do not
know his name but like I know his story
let me just fight it because like
honestly I'm not gonna disrespect his
story by like not knowing his name
he's from Maryland tennis player U.S
open Maryland
Francis tiafo his story is incredible so
his him and his family uh where do they
immigrate from he was from his parents
were from okay whatever I'm butchering
this whole story whatever his dad was a
custodian in a tennis facility they
lived at the facility and exchange his
son got to like play and train for free
became one of the best tennis players in
the world he made it so far in the US
Open I don't think he won this year but
like he's uh he's the next wave yeah
yeah so I feel like all these guys like
they're like they're getting old
yeah how old was that guy Francis tiafo
is
24. like it's his time it's coming
it's his time
that's exciting anyways but I wanted to
talk about this new Taylor Jenkins read
book Harry Soto because we love Taylor
Jenkins read she's like probably one of
the Premier authors of Our Generation
yeah I know Claudia's like mesh because
she loved Evelyn Hugo but Claudia didn't
like Daisy Jones in the six and that's
all you've read and I started Malibu
Rising I'm like oh this stinks
um I read Malibu Rising I actually just
think the books of hers that get popular
aren't the best ones like one true loves
was so good and it's like no one ever
even heard of it I actually read a
different book by her I did it was a DNR
for me it was like after I do or
something like that it was one of her
like romantic books now she writes
really historical fiction yeah like
um interesting historical figures and
when I first started Carrie Soto I was
like regretting it because I was like I
don't want to read a whole book about
tennis and like watch the whole match
yeah over like in the pages but it's so
good and her writing is just so easy to
read and I'm already like 55 I I was
reminded did why she is that author like
right I'm caring about tennis and she's
not making it like painful like love
love okay I hit it then he hit it right
right I get out but did it go out so uh
I would recommend it so far and it's
making me like care about what's going
to become the tennis world well you just
missed the US Open your timing couldn't
be worse that's true
but I do have my morning toast uh tennis
that makes me look like the part so true
also now that you live in Florida like
go play tennis
I know um my neck as well oh right
um we still have the Game of Thrones
recap which I just like need to talk to
you about so was that the fifth Story
that was the fifth Story do you mind if
we dive in please The House of the
Dragon recap is brought to you by away
away makes suitcases bags and other
travel accessories designed to make
moving through the world a lot more
seamless which is a good thing because
travel makes us better people it gives
us different perspectives so no matter
where you're going you can rely on a
Waze range of travel products to solve
real travel problems and get you out
there I travel all the time I just got
home last night with my black away
carry-on it is my favorite suitcase I
have the big one for checked bags I have
the medium size I have the small ones
for carry-ons
so away offers a range of suitcases bags
other travel Essentials that are made of
different materials that come in a
variety of colors and sizes so whatever
you're packing wherever you're going
away has a luggage that will help you
make your trip more seamless all other
suitcases are built to last they have
durable lightweight exteriors that can
withstand the roughest of baggage
handlers and every suitcase comes with
an interior organization system it
includes a built-in compression pad to
help you pack more and a hidden and
removable laundry bag that separates
your dirty clothes they have four 360
degree spinner wheels that are
guaranteed for the smoothest roll and a
TSA approved combination lock that keeps
all your belongings safe with a sleeve
that slides over your suitcase away
suitcases bags are working seamlessly
together to move as one and they offer
free shipping and returns for any
non-personalized item within the
contiguous US Canada and the UK they
also have a 100 day free trial on
everything that they make so take the
product out live with it travel with it
get lost with it for 100 days and if you
decide it's not for you you can return
any non-personalized item for a full
refund start your 100-day trial and chop
the entire away lineup of travel
Essentials including their best-selling
suitcases and bags at awaytravel.com
toast that's awaytravel.com toast
all right house of the Dragon we had a
wedding raniera is marrying her cousin
whose name I could not remember for the
life of me lanor Lenor who is Sir
lorick's son what's the dad's name
cordless cordless Valerian
um and it's a pretty good match because
like they seem to have a nice
arrangement like they meet and she's
like listen I got a man you got a man
let's just like do what we have to do be
friends I actually think of all the ways
you could be like set up it's not a
terrible way like of course everyone
wants a great love but back then you had
to be able to just stand the person you
were married to and it seems like they
had a nice respect for one another but
then um
her future husband's boyfriend had to
[ __ ] around and he found out like I
don't know why he was going around
threatenings to Christian
but that's what happened right like I
couldn't really figure out what because
at first we're focusing on this gorgeous
moment between Rainier and her man's
there I love that her and Damon only
speak in Valerian
um and she's basically just like you
have a problem with the wedding great
whisk me away to Dragonstone and let's
[ __ ] like let's just do it already Uncle
um and I think she's like making some
Headway with him but then chaos erupts
and I don't even know what happens
yeah so I think it's just that I think
that
um
laner's lover provoked sir Kristen he
like lost his mind he's also just like
kind of in love with Rainier like wants
to give it all up for her so he's not in
the good heads no he's not in a good
headspace his mental health is suffering
right he was about to kill himself right
so uh I think he burst and he attacked
that man yeah he attacked that man it
was so sad that like what is the the
play nor that Lena wears like one true
love is gone like that was so sad and
then he had to like get married to
rhaenyra in the pool of his boyfriend's
blood like it was [ __ ] terrible
um
I'm shocked that they actually got
married I thought the wedding would be
stopped I think you know the king
dropping dead in the middle of your
wedding does dead he's not dead you
don't think so he's not dead he's in the
previous for next week next week jumps a
few years the king is looking [ __ ]
rough oh he's still alive okay okay he's
still alive so are they married that's
when we get new actress yeah they're
married oh so this was officially the
last episode with the queen raniera
um
and I know it just like feels that way
because like I'm averse to change but
like she's my only Rainier and I don't
know if I'm gonna be as like obsessed
with her [ __ ] her uncle when it's
some other [ __ ] like I
I'm obsessed as it is now
but like how there's no point in them
[ __ ] if they are not going to be
married no totally totally totally when
I say [ __ ] I mean like get together for
life laner have to die oh yeah by the
way like if if they're gonna end up and
I do believe that they're OTP Damon and
raniera like laner is going to be killed
in one way or another speaking of dead
spouses the way I was not expecting
Damon's wife to be so cute like the way
he talked about her like big bronze
[ __ ] I'm like oh she's like this wench
who's stuck in the veil
um but she was cute she was as athletic
she loved to hunt she definitely had
like a thing with her cousin
um I was shocked she deserved better she
deserved better and that what a way to
die oh terrible
and he still loved Damon obsessed like
if only like someone would do that for
me you know
yeah what's not to like what's not to
laugh it's literally like I'm obsessed
wow are you not no I am but like she
didn't have to go like that no it was
bad but you know what like that's what
they did back then like I can't hold
Damon to a higher standard like terrible
things happened all the time back then
it was just like the way of life
yeah and the queenies coming out she's
really pissing me off she's entering her
villain era I'm glad she found sir
Kristen because I didn't want him to go
um and he needed someone and I actually
feel like they should get together
because like why not he already broke
his chest today and she's so [ __ ]
miserable she needs a good dick she
needs a good dick and down and Sir
Christian can get that but he's so in
love with Rainier I don't know if he
could can you blame him no I literally
cannot so next week it's um it's a few
years in the future maybe like 10 even
and there's a lot of kids I don't know
whose kids they are sure but there's a
lot of them
but it makes it difficult to get
comfortable in a certain space you know
I think after this jump
they're done moving oh because the kids
like aegon how old is that Allison's kid
he must be 15. so he's like Joffrey age
you know like could take the throne if
the king died you know he gives Joffrey
energy for sure
um
I I know you have a theory and I like I
want to encourage theories but like your
theories are always right and like I do
like to be surprised okay I'm sharing my
theory okay I'm taking my headphones off
because like you're totally right like
you're always right you're so smart like
I honestly I like being dumb I'm always
wrong I like being dumb in this show
because I'm always surprised I want to
share with the people just I'm gonna
take myself there's no point no no if
you don't know I want you to share
no it's it's like not that it's it's
fine
okay she took her headphones off uh next
week there's a ton of kids running
around and a lot of them are black of
hair which means that they're not the
kids of rhaenyra and uh lane or Valerian
or else they would have you know very
light hair so I think like her affair
with sir Kristen has resulted in babies
that are not her husbands and
um
I don't know what that means for the
realm okay girly I'm done
that's my theory
you ready yeah how did you feel like you
feel like you're right
yeah I don't know what it means though
it's just something that I saw on from
next week or something okay
um I'm just like so obsessed with this
show I can't like I'm so excited I'm so
grateful to be like yeah like to have
something you know that we're all a part
of to live for
yeah it's so good
it is good I didn't love last night's
episode though I'm not gonna lie it
didn't like do a lot for me I mean for
me like a good episode constitute how
much screen time I get with Damon and
rhaenyra and how physical they are with
one another
um but that
like end scene made it worth it I
thought it was a fine episode it's just
painful to watch the king it's like
[ __ ] just die already like between the
nose and the hand and the eyes like just
die
yeah and what are you doing big dope
taking a big trip
to visit the valerians when you're not
well go to sleep but he's like so funny
he doesn't even try and conceal it no I
know like I actually do like him I know
me too and like every time he coughs
it's like oh this is the end but no he's
still around got it so I guess the fact
that he didn't die and he just like
fainted makes the scene at the end like
kind of hilarious
yeah because it's like what else could
go wrong today and were they supposed to
be getting married like in a private
ceremony right after no they saw that's
what I saw in the director's thing where
they were like this King he keeps like
having these Grand plans for his tourney
and his yeah and for the hunt and he
can't kill and for this wedding he's
like [ __ ] it just get married yeah you
know what it's a very Jewish way just
very superstitious like don't just go
just go
yeah but now they're married and I
didn't want them to be I know and like I
think that raniera's husband is like
probably [ __ ] pissed and bitter about
his man being killed at the hands of her
man
um and I don't think it's gonna be this
great relationship where they both you
know balance each other out and respect
one another I think he's going to be
really resentful and mean I think that
they thought that they fooled everyone
and that they figured out life and they
played themselves congratulations you
played yourself yeah
no I and I do like that they skip ahead
because now it's like next week we'll
like we'll know what happens status of
their marriage yeah so I do like that
but it's like it's you're just
conditioned to watch TV shows and like
find out what happens the next day you
know yeah but I guess we'll be moving
into that sort of I don't even know what
the new Rainier looks like I'm sure
she's great but like I just love this
actress like so much
you should watch a place to call home
because she's in it yeah I should
that's also a really good way to like I
remember when I was watching um Nash
film and spoiler alert major spoiler in
case you're watching Nashville
um Rayna James died but at the same time
I had been watching Friday Night Lights
and so she was still alive to me yeah
you're keeping her to grief you're
keeping her energy her spirit with you
yeah
um so TV recap
was that and that's our show correct
that is our show thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning testimony
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
to podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so that Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio I haven't really cast box all the
places so everyone listen to podcasts
find out some morning tell us leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are tickets
available to my tour at girl with no
job.com tour have an amazing Tuesday
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day bye